is from the daily wire says airbnb has
banned michelle malkin blocking the
right-wing political commentator from
booking reservations on its platform
uh and this has finally been by
confirmed by the company
malcolm who has aligned herself in
recent months with nick fuentes's
america first movement said on twitter
wednesday that she and her husband had
been banned from staying at airbnb
locations the vacation rental company
deleted malkin's account because of her
participation in the 2021 american
renaissance conference according to an
email malcolm posted online
uh the email said
it has come to our attention that you
are a keynote speaker for the 2021
american renaissance conference earlier
this month in tennessee airbnb's
community policies prohibit people who
are members of are actively associated
with known hate groups
due to your promotion and participation
in a known white nationalist and white
supremacist conference we have
determined that we will remove your
account from
airbnb this is consistent with action
we've taken to ban people associated
with this conference in past years
the platform confirmed uh malkin's ban
in a statement to the daily beast on
wednesday consistent with our policies
if we become aware of users who are
members of or are actively affiliated
with hate groups we remove them from
airbnb
now
what airbnb has not provided as far as i
know thus far
is
uh
any example
any other example of them doing this
banning someone for being associated
with a quote known hate group
we should also note by the way that
michelle malkin
who's uh being banned from airbnb and
being de-platformed as a white
supremacist is not white
which you would think might be relevant
here
not exactly sure how you can be a white
supremacist when you're not white
but this is
um what one of those things that even
people on the right even now
some of them kind of skimming over
because they say oh well michelle malkin
she's she's too extreme for my tastes
she's uh she's uh getting involved with
nick fuentes and all this and so that's
that's we're not gonna be worried about
that
well you should worry about it for for
reasons of basic self-preservation
this is a definite this is a definite
escalation here
it's a quite a foreseeable escalation
but it's an escalation
because at least
platforms like twitter and youtube and
all that spotify and all the rest of
them um
when they de-platform you for your
opinions
well they can always claim they can
always say that well this is a platform
for
expressing ideas and these ideas that
you're that you express are harmful and
dangerous and all and even if that's
nonsense since it's totally bogus they
are at least platforms for expressing
ideas that's why the platforms exist
but airbnb is just a a place where you
rent
vacation homes or if you're going to
stay in an area for a few days and you
you rent out it's that they're not
platforms for the expression of ideas
um as far as i know michelle malkin was
not she wasn't hosting the event
at the airbnb location
she wasn't even having an after party
for everybody afterwards
she was just staying
there and it's not that that airbnb is
saying oh you you can't stay
uh at an airbnb location
while you're attending this event it's
like you can never stay at another
location
because we have decided that your
opinions are unacceptable well i hope
you enjoyed that clip for the matt wall
show if you did go ahead and hit that
subscribe button right down there so you
can stay up to date on all of our future
content